I have such a great recommendation for
you today not long ago my friend Charlie
gave me a copy of the book the lessons
of history by will and Ariel Durant will
and Ariel Durant just their biography is
interesting go on Wikipedia and read a
little bit about them they have a book
called the lessons of history and the
only way I can describe it is it's an
incredibly concise summary of culture
and civilization of a mankind okay and
it's a dozen or so pretty short essays
two to four pages each the books only
about a hundred and ten pages okay it is
written so well it condenses such
complex ideas based on hundreds or even
many more years of survey and
understanding of humanity into a couple
of different pages it looks at war it
looks at racism it looks at the history
of history I could not possibly
recommend this book more highly because
of the way in which it provides
perspective about so many of the broader
issues that continue to resurface for
humans and you know one effort I'm
making in terms of what I read Pat is
I'm thinking when I we have a limited
amount of time to read write well for it
for anything in life but reading is one
of those things that you're only gonna
read a certain number of books and I'm
trying to ask myself the question is the
subject matter of the book something
that is only relevant based on a fad or
trend right now or is this a book that
is going to be more broadly informative
because it relates to areas of of the
world areas of life that are either
recurring or ever-present and if by that
standard this book should be really
close to the top of the list for
everybody right because everyone always
talks about history repeating itself or
so for example Napoleon tried to invade
Russia failed Hitler tried to invade
Russia also failed so these things keep
happening and take on different forms
and now with the the rise of Donald
Trump and his authoritarian rhetoric yes
we can we can look back even just a
hundred year
ago or less and draw comparisons to
leaders of other authoritarian regime
and the other thing that the book
actually a lot of it applies to what's
going on right now there's one chapter I
forget which chapter or essay it is and
it talks about how fundamentally freedom
and equality are opposed forces maybe
not in the literal sense but if you have
total freedom you're not going to have
equality because total freedom
encompasses the ability of some humans
to oppress others and for wealth to
concentrate significantly so total
freedom is the opposite of total
equality total equality can only be
achieved if you go in a more
authoritarian direction based on the
lessons of history as the book is called
and it really lays out these concepts in
a very very good way and where I end up
after reading a book like this it's
thinking that on most issues of
paramount importance to society and
culture extremist solutions are not
sustainable long term and the book in
talking about some of the cycles that we
see explains how waves of
authoritarianism lead to backlashes that
lead to less authoritarianism which
leads to growth in inequality which
leads to a different type of backlash
and the cycle sort of repeats itself so
in any case yeah this is just one
example of what's in the book the book
is the lessons of history by will and
Ariel Durant you can find this and all
of my recommendations at david
pakman.com slash recommendations